Do you ever knock on wood for good luck? Cross the street if you see a black cat? What about refusing to stay on the 13th floor of a hotel, if the hotel even has a 13th floor? Do you go out of your way to avoid walking under ladders? Even if you don't do these things, you're probably at least familiar with them and other common superstitions. Or maybe you have some personal superstitions,
你是否曾经为了好运而敲木头？看到黑猫就绕道走？如果酒店有13楼，你是否拒绝住在那里，甚至如果酒店根本没有13楼呢？你会特意避开梯子下面走吗？即使你不做这些事，你可能至少也听说过这些以及其他常见的迷信。或者，也许你有一些个人的迷信，
a lucky number, a charm, a ritual that you find indispensable. Superstitious beliefs and behaviors like these are common. But where do superstition come from? What psychological purpose does it serve? And are some types of people more likely than others to be superstitious? What's the connection between superstition and other forms of irrational thinking? And is it possible that your lucky charm or pre-game ritual might actually help you perform better? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association,
比如幸运数字、护身符，或者你觉得不可或缺的仪式。像这样的迷信信仰和行为很常见。但迷信从何而来？它有什么心理作用？某些类型的人是否比其他人更容易迷信？迷信与其他形式的非理性思维之间有什么联系？你的幸运符或赛前仪式是否真的能帮助你表现得更好？欢迎收听《心理学谈话》，这是美国心理学会的旗舰播客，
that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. Our guest today is Dr. Stuart Weiss, author of the books Believing in Magic, The Psychology of Superstition, and Superstition, a very short introduction. Dr. Weiss is a behavioral scientist, teacher, and writer who is often called upon by the media to explain humans' propensity for irrational thinking, including superstition. He was for many years a professor of psychology and chair of the psychology department at Connecticut College. He's now a full-time writer and speaker. He is also a contributing editor at Skeptical Inquirer magazine, where he writes the behavior and belief column. Thank you for joining us today, Dr. Weiss.
旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯。我们今天的嘉宾是斯图尔特·韦斯博士，他是《相信魔法：迷信心理学》和《迷信：非常简短的介绍》等书的作者。韦斯博士是一位行为科学家、教师和作家，经常被媒体邀请来解释人类对非理性思维（包括迷信）的倾向。他曾多年担任康涅狄格学院的心理学教授和心理学系主任。他现在是一名全职作家和演讲者。他还是《怀疑论者调查》杂志的特约编辑，在那里撰写“行为与信仰”专栏。感谢您今天加入我们，韦斯博士。
I'm happy to be here. So as I just said, there are maybe two types of superstitions, the widely shared cultural ones like Black Cats in the number 13, and then personal ones like Lucky Charms and rituals. What unites those two areas and makes something a superstition? How do you define that concept? Well, first of all, let me start by defining. it. I define it fairly broadly in which I say that a superstition is a belief or practice that is inconsistent with our understanding of science. And then I limit it to things that are in some sense
很高兴来到这里。正如我刚才所说，迷信可能有两种类型，一种是像黑猫和数字13这样广泛共享的文化迷信，另一种是像幸运符和仪式这样的个人迷信。是什么将这两个领域结合在一起，使某件事成为迷信？你如何定义这个概念？嗯，首先，让我从定义开始。我给出的定义相当广泛，即迷信是一种与我们对科学的理解不一致的信仰或实践。然后，我将其限制在某种意义上是
pragmatic, either trying to bring on good luck or avoid bad luck. And in terms of the two kinds of superstition that you mention, which is, that's a good way to think about it. And I, I, uh, I do separate out what we would call personal superstitions that are unique to yourself and acquired sort of usually by trial and error from superstitions that are taught to us that we absorb simply by being in the culture and we learn about black cats and ladders and the number 13. And what they have in common, of course, is the need to control, an attempt to to bring about the good thing or avoid the bad thing.
务实的事情，要么是试图带来好运，要么是试图避免厄运。至于你提到的两种迷信，这确实是一种很好的思考方式。我确实将我们所说的个人迷信（对你个人而言是独特的，通常是通过反复试验获得的）与我们被教导的迷信（我们仅仅通过身处某种文化中而吸收的，比如我们了解到的黑猫、梯子和数字13）区分开来。当然，它们的共同点是控制的需要，即试图带来好事或避免坏事。
And as a result, they tend to emerge in circumstances when we have less than perfect control. Two of the kind of conditions that mean that we are going to or more likely to be superstitious are ones where we don't have control and yet we do care very much about what happens about the outcome. So you're a psychologist, but you've also become an expert in the history and the sociology of superstition. How far back in history do we have evidence of superstition?
因此，它们往往出现在我们无法完全掌控的情况下。导致我们迷信或更有可能迷信的两种情况是：我们无法掌控，但又非常关心事情的结果。所以你是一位心理学家，但你也成为了迷信历史和社会学方面的专家。我们在历史上能追溯到多早的迷信证据？
From the beginning, I mean, from the beginning of history. I mean, the problem, of course, is that what we call superstition is based in our dominant belief system, which is Western science. You know, we are all post-enlightenment people who have adopted science and reasons. as our standards. But looking backwards, humans have always wanted to have control over things that they couldn't control and to know what was coming up in the future. And so many things that the ancient people did in Greece or earlier would look like superstition
从一开始，我是说，从历史的开端。当然，问题在于我们所谓的迷信是基于我们占主导地位的信仰体系，即西方科学。你知道，我们都是后启蒙时代的人，已经采用了科学和理性作为我们的标准。但回顾过去，人类一直希望能够控制那些他们无法控制的事情，并预知未来。因此，古希腊人或更早时期的人所做的许多事情，在我们看来
to us. And so the desire and the practices have been there all along. The most important thing about the history of superstition, it's the history of a word. It is a label that has been applied to many kinds of beliefs and practices. And in general, most of history, that word has been applied to the unorthodox or the unsupported beliefs of the time. So in the Roman era, Christians emerged, and their beliefs and their practices were called superstitious because they were not the standard authorized beliefs of the time. When the Roman Empire changed to being a Christian empire, suddenly the old Roman gods and beliefs were thought to be superstitious.
就像迷信一样。所以，这种欲望和实践一直存在。关于迷信历史最重要的一点是，它是关于一个词的历史。这是一个被应用于多种信仰和实践的标签。总的来说，在大部分历史中，这个词被用来指代当时非正统或未经证实的信仰。因此，在罗马时代，基督徒出现了，他们的信仰和实践被称为迷信，因为它们不是当时标准的授权信仰。当罗马帝国转变为基督教帝国时，旧的罗马神祇和信仰突然被认为是迷信。
So, you know, what goes around comes around. But we now, of course, in the modern age, we hopefully have. have passed through the scientific age, and now we adopt science and reason as our standards. And so when we call something superstitious, it's because it doesn't meet that criteria. And it doesn't fit with that worldview. We may end up airing this podcast on Friday the 13th. We're certainly talking about that. I'm just wondering if you can explain the history of that particular superstition.
所以，你知道，风水轮流转。但当然，在现代，我们希望已经度过了科学时代，现在我们采用科学和理性作为我们的标准。因此，当我们称某事为迷信时，是因为它不符合这些标准。它不符合那个世界观。我们可能会在13号星期五播出这期播客。我们当然在谈论这个。我只是想知道你是否能解释一下那个特定迷信的历史。
You know, what's unlucky about Friday the 13th? There are several theories. There are at least three dominant theories of where Friday the 13th came from. I'm going to give you first the one that I believe is the strongest. And there's a fellow who wrote a book on the topic who convinced me that this was the most common origin of the superstition. But anyway, it comes from originally the idea of 13 camps from The Last Supper and 13 people at a table. And of course, you know, Jesus was betrayed. and so 13 people at a table was thought to be an unlucky thing or groups of 13 people.
你知道，13号星期五有什么不吉利的？有几种理论。关于13号星期五的起源，至少有三种主流理论。我先告诉你我认为最有力的一种。有一位写过相关书籍的人说服了我，这是该迷信最常见的起源。但无论如何，它最初源于《最后的晚餐》中13个人坐在桌子旁的想法。当然，你知道，耶稣被出卖了，所以桌子旁有13个人或13个人的群体被认为是不吉利的。
And that became, was a superstition for quite a while. And then at some point really fairly late in the 19th century, 13 got sort of freed from the table and got to be unlucky in and of itself in any context. And then it sort of adhered to Friday because Friday was already an unlucky day. Friday was Hangman's Day. It was a day that people got hung in much of Europe. And so it comes around every once in a while, once or twice a year, there's a Friday the 13th. And so people noted there also was a book and a movie. The movie is now lost to history, but there was an early book and movie that also helped to solidify the Friday the 13th.
这在很长一段时间里都是一种迷信。然后在19世纪相当晚的时候，13号从桌子上“解放”出来，在任何情况下都变得不吉利。然后它就附着在了星期五上，因为星期五本来就是一个不吉利的日子。星期五是“绞刑日”。在欧洲大部分地区，这是人们被绞死的日子。所以它每隔一段时间就会出现一次，一年一两次，会有13号星期五。所以人们注意到还有一本书和一部电影。那部电影现在已经失传了，但早期的书和电影也帮助巩固了13号星期五的
superstition. It seems that there are a lot of superstitions around lucky and unlucky numbers. Some of those are cultural superstitions like the number 13 or eight and four in Chinese culture. And then there are the personal superstitions that people have around their own lucky numbers. Like if you play the lottery every week, you have to play the same numbers. Do you have any thoughts on why numbers are such fertile ground for superstition? Well, it's a good question. I think it's because there are a couple of reasons. One is because they are sort of arbitrary to begin with. And so it's easy to sort of stick something onto them.
迷信。似乎有很多关于幸运和不幸数字的迷信。其中一些是文化迷信，比如数字13，或者中国文化中的8和4。然后是人们围绕自己的幸运数字所持有的个人迷信。比如如果你每周都买彩票，你必须买同样的数字。你对为什么数字是迷信的沃土有什么看法吗？嗯，这是一个好问题。我认为原因有几个。一个是它们最初是某种程度上任意的。所以很容易把某种东西附着在它们身上。
There's no interfering association. And so if you just find that five is your lucky number, then there's not going to be any competing idea with that. And numbers do come up. I mean, you can't avoid them. They do come up from time to time. And because they're arbitrary, we try to sort of make, some meaning out of them. And so I think that's a common thing. You mentioned the eight
没有干扰性的关联。所以如果你发现5是你的幸运数字，那么就不会有任何与之竞争的想法。而且数字确实会出现。我的意思是，你无法避开它们。它们确实会不时出现。因为它们是任意的，我们试图从中赋予某种意义。所以我认为这是一件很常见的事情。你提到了8
and four. This is another way in which, and this is in Chinese culture, where again, a completely random association with an arbitrary number is what causes those superstitions. So the number eight is associated with the sound for prosperity or something in the Chinese language, the symbol is, and the number four is associated with death, you know, the name death. So that random association, which has nothing to do with, it's just the sound of the word, is enough to make those two numbers special in Chinese culture. And you'll find that many, many Chinese phone numbers have eights in them, in very few fours. And the pricing of products in the marketplace,
和4。这是另一种方式，这是在中国文化中，同样，与任意数字的完全随机关联导致了这些迷信。所以数字8与中文里“发”或类似的声音相关联，而数字4与“死”这个名字相关联。所以这种随机的关联，与词义无关，仅仅是词的发音，就足以使这两个数字在中国文化中变得特殊。你会发现许多中国人的电话号码里都有8，而很少有4。市场上的产品定价，
avoids the number four quite often. So it doesn't come up. And so if you happen to have an apartment for sale on the fourth floor of a building, your chances of selling it to a Chinese person might be diminished. That's right. That's right.
经常避开数字4。所以它不会出现。因此，如果你碰巧有一套公寓要卖，位于大楼的四楼，你把它卖给中国人的机会可能会降低。没错。没错。
You might have to offer a better deal than that. You know, in case of the number 13, I discovered that, you know, most hotels, don't have a 13th floor. You sort of made reference to that in your introduction. And of course, they do, but they just don't number it 13. There was a study done that showed that approximately 80% of the buildings in New York City that could have a 13th floor don't. And I think that's a straight economic decision, a business decision, that it makes it easier to rent the hotel rooms or
你可能不得不提供更好的交易。你知道，关于数字13，我发现，你知道，大多数酒店都没有13楼。你在介绍中提到了这一点。当然，它们有，只是不编号为13。有一项研究表明，纽约市大约80%本可以有13楼的建筑都没有。我认为这是一个直接的经济决策，一个商业决策，即让酒店房间或
office space on the 14th floor than on the 13th floor. But the interesting thing, I found, if I can go on just a little bit more about this, is that in Russia, they take a different approach. In Moscow, rather than eliminating the 13th floor, which they sort of scoff at, they offer a discount for apartments on the 13th floor, that you get a slightly better price. I mean, I don't know what happens when you turn around and need to sell that space again, but, you know, that's the approach they take. How common are superstitious beliefs and behavior in the U.S.? Have you seen any survey data that talks about how many people consider themselves superstitious
14楼的办公空间比13楼更容易出租。但有趣的是，我发现，如果我能再多说一点，在俄罗斯，他们采取了不同的方法。在莫斯科，他们没有取消13楼（他们对此嗤之以鼻），而是为13楼的公寓提供折扣，价格稍微好一点。我的意思是，我不知道当你转手需要再次出售那个空间时会发生什么，但你知道，这就是他们采取的方法。在美国，迷信信仰和行为有多普遍？你有没有看到过任何关于有多少人认为自己迷信的调查数据
or some variation of that term? There have been a few studies, surveys over the years. Gallup used to do one every once in a while, but they have sort of tapered off on that. In terms of the individual superstitions, the numbers tend to be fairly low, somewhere between, like black cats or ladders or something like this of the cultural superstitions. The numbers are between 10 and 20 percent of people would say that they believe in those. But if you just say overall, are you superstitious or not, the surveys tend to be higher than there are about 50 percent of people in the last survey I saw, which is fairly old, of Americans,
或该术语的某种变体？多年来有一些研究和调查。盖洛普过去偶尔会做一次，但他们在这方面已经逐渐减少了。就个人迷信而言，数字往往相当低，大约在10%到20%之间，比如黑猫或梯子之类的文化迷信。但如果你只是笼统地问“你迷信吗？”，调查结果往往会更高，在我看到的最后一次调查中，大约50%的美国人，
said that they were at least a little superstitious. So I think it's still quite widespread and maybe even increasing, I don't know. Well, and I know I'm not being original here by asking you this question, but are some cultures more superstitious than others? And if so, why do you think that might be? I used to say no to that question, but the more I study the Chinese culture, the more I think that it is very superstitious. They have, I mean, we've already talked about the number superstitions, but they also have superstitions about. the color red, for example, being lucky. And so wedding dresses are frequently red in color.
说他们至少有一点迷信。所以我认为它仍然非常普遍，甚至可能在增加，我不知道。嗯，我知道问你这个问题并不新颖，但有些文化是否比其他文化更迷信？如果是这样，你认为为什么会这样？我过去对这个问题说不，但研究中国文化越多，我就越认为它非常迷信。他们有，我的意思是，我们已经谈到了数字迷信，但他们也有关于红色的迷信，例如，认为红色是幸运的。所以婚纱经常是红色的。
And you notice the Chinese restaurants often have red as a dominant color. So there are just a lot of things in the Chinese culture that are luck-oriented. And products are often designed with that in mind. They avoid, you know, red products do well in many cases when they're sold. So this is, it's interesting, but the business world and marketers have taken note of all these things. And there are, for example, American hotels make special, or at least are advised to take special note of things that might affect Asian travelers as being lucky or unlucky. But many cultures are, just to skip back to your question, many cultures are superstitious. It's not just the Chinese, you know, there are Irish superstitions, there are British superstitions.
你会注意到中餐馆通常以红色为主色调。所以中国文化中有很多与运气相关的东西。产品设计时也经常考虑到这一点。他们避免，你知道，红色产品在很多情况下销售得很好。所以这很有趣，但商业世界和营销人员已经注意到了所有这些事情。例如，美国酒店会特别注意，或者至少被建议特别注意那些可能影响亚洲游客认为幸运或不吉利的事情。但许多文化都是，回到你的问题，许多文化都是迷信的。不仅仅是中国人，你知道，有爱尔兰迷信，有英国迷信。
It's everywhere. And there's nobody who can hold their head up and say that we're completely immune. Well, my mother's family came from Italy, and I grew up with a lot of Italian-American friends. And we had some beliefs that I think were particular to that background. For example, my great-a-a-aunt would say, you never put a hat on the bed because it's bad luck. Someone's going to die. And my grandparents would say that my mother was overlooked. That was the term that they used, that she was overlooked as a baby, which they meant someone gave her the evil eye. Although in her case, they said it was a good thing.
它无处不在。没有人能昂首挺胸地说我们完全免疫。嗯，我母亲的家族来自意大利，我是在很多意大利裔美国朋友中长大的。我们有一些我认为是那个背景特有的信仰。例如，我的姨婆会说，你永远不要把帽子放在床上，因为那是不吉利的。有人会死。我的祖父母会说我母亲被“忽视”了。这是他们使用的术语，说她小时候被“忽视”了，意思是有人对她施了“邪眼”。虽然在她的例子中，他们说这是一件好事。
It's why she was smart. But could you talk about the origins of the belief in the evil eye and the things that people do to ward it off? Yeah. Well, as far as the origins, it is very old. And I don't know exactly where it started. I believe it's mentioned in the Bible, but it's even older than that. But the thing that's the most interesting about the evil eye is that it is very widespread. I mean, Italy, of course, is very much a part of the evil eye culture.
这就是她聪明的原因。但你能谈谈对邪眼信仰的起源以及人们为了抵御它所做的事情吗？是的。嗯，至于起源，它非常古老。我不知道它具体是从哪里开始的。我相信圣经中提到了它，但它比那还要古老。但关于邪眼最有趣的事情是它非常普遍。我的意思是，意大利当然是邪眼文化的重要组成部分。
Malocchio. Malocchio, that's right. So the evil eye is very widespread, but it is different for different cultures. And the way it's dealt with in different cultures is quite interesting. So it's very popular in South Asia. Indians, Bangladeshis, and others believe in it. And it's also very popular in the Middle East and Italy, I think less so in Western Europe and also in South America. I grew up in the Midwest as a sort of default Protestant.
Malocchio。Malocchio，没错。所以邪眼非常普遍，但在不同的文化中有所不同。在不同文化中处理它的方式非常有趣。它在南亚非常流行。印度人、孟加拉人和其他人都相信它。它在中东和意大利也非常流行，我认为在西欧和南美则较少。我在中西部长大，是一个默认的新教徒。
I'd never heard of it before. And it wasn't until I was teaching superstition that a student from Persexuals, Peru first told me about it, and then I began to hear much more. And so the interesting thing for me is the fact that, you know, throughout the world, there are different sort of countermeasures that you use to avoid the malocchio or the evil eye, depending upon where you are. And there's a whole jewelry industry that has cropped up to help people distract the evil eye away. In Italy, for example, there's a horn-shaped object that you buy and wear, and it's supposed to distract someone's evil eye away from you.
我以前从未听说过它。直到我教授迷信课程时，一个来自秘鲁的学生才第一次告诉我，然后我开始听到更多。所以对我来说有趣的是，你知道，在世界各地，根据你所在的地方，有不同的对抗措施来避免Malocchio或邪眼。整个珠宝行业已经兴起，帮助人们分散邪眼的注意力。例如，在意大利，有一种角状物体，你买来戴着，它应该能把别人的邪眼从你身上分散开。
And in the Middle East, they have the Homsah, which is a hand-shaped jewelry, which is very popular. It usually has an eye in the middle of it. Turks have these blue-and-white Nazars. They're very beautiful. It's often made of glass that look like a bull's-eye, and they're supposed to also distract the evil eye. So the way in which it's dealt with in each country,
在中东，他们有Homsah，这是一种手形的珠宝，非常受欢迎。它中间通常有一只眼睛。土耳其人有这些蓝白相间的Nazar。它们非常漂亮。它通常由玻璃制成，看起来像靶心，它们也应该分散邪眼的注意力。所以每个国家处理它的方式，
the basic idea is still the same, right? Usually it's that you have something that you really value, and the idea is that the person with the evil eye is envious of you and can somehow harm it. But babies are a common thing that people are worried about, that someone's going to harm the baby. And so the idea is, is that if we can just distract the evil eye, or in the case of some of these jewelry items,
基本思想是一样的，对吧？通常是你拥有一些你非常珍视的东西，而想法是拥有邪眼的人嫉妒你，并能以某种方式伤害它。但婴儿是人们担心的常见事物，担心有人会伤害婴儿。所以想法是，如果我们能分散邪眼的注意力，或者在某些珠宝物品的情况下，
actually reflect the evil eye back at the perpetrator, that will be protected. And so it's interesting. Also, in Italy, in particular, not to go on too long about this, but I love this topic. If you're ill, there's apparently, and I don't know if you've heard of this one, But there is a diagnostic procedure involving getting a small bowl of water and dropping olive oil on top. And if a person is sick, if the olive oil appears as just drops floating on the water, then the illness was not caused by the evil eye. But if the oil looks runny on the top of the water, at least as I've heard it, then that means your illness was caused by the evil eye.
实际上把邪眼反射回施害者身上，那就会受到保护。所以这很有趣。此外，在意大利，特别是不想在这个话题上说太多，但我喜欢这个话题。如果你生病了，显然，我不知道你是否听说过这个，但有一个诊断程序，涉及拿一个小碗水，在上面滴橄榄油。如果一个人病了，如果橄榄油只是作为水滴漂浮在水面上，那么疾病不是由邪眼引起的。但如果油在水面上看起来很稀，至少我听说的是这样，那么这意味着你的疾病是由邪眼引起的。
I'm not sure what that means as far as how to treat it, but that's apparently an old technique, which is, I think, completely Italian. There's no, there's no, you know, the olive oil part of it would make that so. But getting back to the psychology of superstition, what are the psychological processes that are going on when people develop superstitions and make these behaviors part of their lives?
我不确定这意味着如何治疗它，但这显然是一种古老的技术，我认为，完全是意大利式的。没有，没有，你知道，橄榄油的部分会使它如此。但回到迷信的心理学，当人们产生迷信并将这些行为作为生活的一部分时，心理过程是什么？
Is there some psychological purpose? I think you talked about control as one of them. Yes, yes. It's very much the case for all of them. There are very few instances where if you have complete control and you know what's going to happen, then that you employ a superstition. It's very rare, even if the outcome is very important,
有什么心理目的吗？我想你谈到了控制作为其中之一。是的，是的。对所有这些情况来说确实如此。如果你有完全的控制权并且知道会发生什么，那么你使用迷信的例子非常少。这非常罕见，即使结果非常重要，
it's only in those circumstances where you can't be certain of the outcome that a superstition comes about. So control is very big. In the case of personal superstitions, the process is a sort of trial and error thing. There's a famous experiment that was done by B.F. Skinner with pigeons in which he put the pigeons in a chamber and they were hungry. And he gave them food for a brief period every 15 seconds, and they didn't have to do anything. They could just sit there if they wanted and wait for the food to come back and eat it and then wait again until it came back again. but they didn't just sit there.
只有在你无法确定结果的情况下，迷信才会出现。所以控制非常重要。在个人迷信的情况下，这个过程是一种反复试验的事情。B.F.斯金纳对鸽子做了一个著名的实验，他把鸽子放在一个盒子里，它们很饿。他每15秒给它们喂一次食物，持续一小段时间，它们不需要做任何事情。如果它们愿意，它们可以坐在那里，等待食物回来，吃掉它，然后再次等待，直到它再次回来。但它们并没有只是坐在那里。
What they did is they moved around and it was as if they established rituals and each bird had a different ritual, but they established rituals as if they thought that that ritual was what brought the food, you know, and Skinner's interpretation of that was that it was an accidental relationship
它们所做的是四处走动，就好像它们建立了仪式，每只鸟都有不同的仪式，但它们建立了仪式，就好像它们认为那个仪式是带来食物的原因，你知道，斯金纳对那件事的解释是，这是一种偶然的关系
between the two and so on. So now that study actually has been, you know, batted around with some controversy over the years, but it's a nice metaphor for what we do as well, is that if you wear a new tie and you go and do a really great performance at a talk or a presentation, you might just wear that tie each time you have to do that present, a presentation, because it feels like it has some special quality. And that's all it takes for many people. you probably have to be open to the idea of a superstition in general before you would do that. But often they are those sort of random associations.
在两者之间，等等。所以现在那个研究实际上已经，你知道，多年来一直伴随着一些争议，但它也是我们所做事情的一个很好的隐喻，即如果你戴上一条新领带，去进行了一场非常精彩的演讲或展示，你可能每次必须做那个展示时都会戴上那条领带，因为它感觉好像有什么特殊的品质。对许多人来说，这就足够了。你可能必须对迷信的想法持开放态度，然后你才会这样做。但通常它们是那种随机的关联。
And I think what sustains it in the long run is that, of course, it's not that it's magic. I don't want to burst any bubbles here, but it's not, there is no magic that would make a tie help you in a practical sense. but it probably acquires some psychological value where you just feel better wearing it in the moment. Doesn't mean that you will perform better later on, although the theory, you know, the question that it raises is, is the psychological benefit, even though it's not magical, will that translate into a better performance, you know, later on? And that is the million dollar question that a number of psychologists are trying to answer. It's sort of a superstition placebo effect. Yes, yes. And I mean, this is particularly prevalent, I think, among athletes, whether they're wearing their lucky socks or, of course, there is the famous, all the stories around Wade Boggs who had some incredible rituals that he went through before he played ball games.
我认为长期维持它的是，当然，它不是魔法。我不想在这里戳破任何泡沫，但它不是，没有魔法能让领带在实际意义上帮助你。但它可能获得了一些心理价值，让你在当下戴着它感觉更好。并不意味着你以后会表现得更好，尽管这个理论，你知道，它提出的问题是，心理上的好处，即使它不是魔法，会转化为以后的更好表现吗？这就是百万美元的问题，许多心理学家正试图回答。这有点像迷信的安慰剂效应。是的，是的。我的意思是，我认为这在运动员中尤其普遍，无论是他们穿着幸运袜，还是当然，关于韦德·博格斯的所有故事，他在打球前经历了一些不可思议的仪式。
Can you just talk about him because I'm not sure that all our listeners know what Wade Boggs used to go through. Yeah. kept help to keep the you know Wade Boggs alive as a memory he's long he's long since retired from baseball but he was a he was a third basement uh for both the red sox and the yankees which is quite a trick when you think about it and uh he he was an he was a very good hitter he was he won the batting title several times and he is in the hall of fame uh but he was probably one of the most superstitious athletes you know ever and that's saying something that's because athletes really are superstitious. But in high school, he had a chicken dinner or chicken for
你能谈谈他吗，因为我不确定我们所有的听众都知道韦德·博格斯过去经历过什么。是的。帮助保持了，你知道，韦德·博格斯作为一个记忆活着，他早已从棒球界退役，但他曾是红袜队和洋基队的三垒手，当你想到这一点时，这真是一个绝活，而且他是一个非常好的击球手，他多次获得击球冠军，并且进入了名人堂，但他可能是史上最迷信的运动员之一，这说明了一些问题，因为运动员确实很迷信。但在高中时，他午餐吃了鸡肉，
lunch or something and then went out and hit four for four. He was at bat four times and he got four hits. And that was it. From that point on, he never didn't eat chicken before going, you know, before playing in a baseball game. And so he believed, he really believed that chicken, made him hit better, which of course is scientifically not possible, but nonetheless, he believed it, and it probably helped him psychologically. He also had many, many rituals that he performed at the game. One of the things that is something that encourages the development of superstitions is having some anxiety about something that's coming up, and then having time to fill, where you're, you know, you can't practice, you can't sleep, you can't do any of the other, the practical things that would prepare you for the performance, and yet there's time to fill.
或者类似的东西，然后出去打了四次四中。他有四次击球机会，他得到了四次安打。就是这样。从那时起，他在去打棒球比赛之前，从来没有不吃鸡肉。所以他相信，他真的相信鸡肉让他打得更好，这在科学上当然是不可能的，但尽管如此，他相信，这可能在心理上帮助了他。他在比赛中还执行了许多许多仪式。鼓励迷信发展的事情之一是对即将发生的事情感到焦虑，然后有时间去填补，在那里你，你知道，你不能练习，你不能睡觉，你不能做任何其他为表现做准备的实际事情，但却有时间去填补。
And so he actually had something like a three-hour-long ritual that he went through prior to each game. And it involved, you know, a certain number of kinds of practice throws and not stepping on the line of, you know, the first. foul line when you entered the field and then stepping on it when you left. And he also would write the Hebrew letter Kai in the dirt as he stepped into the batter's box for luck. And so he was really out there. But, you know, he also hit very well. So he didn't have any disconfirming information that would stop him. I used to watch him play when I lived in New York. I didn't know what he was doing with his toe in the dirt, but now I do.
所以他实际上有一个大约三小时长的仪式，他在每场比赛前都会经历。它涉及，你知道，一定数量的练习投球，进入场地时不要踩到一垒的界外线，离开时再踩。当他走进击球区时，他还会用脚在泥土里写下希伯来字母“Kai”以求好运。所以他真的很特别。但是，你知道，他也打得很好。所以他没有任何会让他停止的否定信息。我以前住纽约时常看他打球。我不知道他在泥土里用脚趾在做什么，但现在我知道了。
Yes. So there are a lot of religious beliefs and practices, and I don't mean to be disrespectful, but they seem a lot like superstition. I mean, I was raised a Roman Catholic. We would bless ourselves with holy water as we entered the church. The sacraments of baptism and confirmation involve casting out the devil. They're Catholic churches, especially in Europe and South America, that display relics of saints, which are actually human bones.
是的。所以有很多宗教信仰和实践，我无意不敬，但它们看起来很像迷信。我的意思是，我是作为罗马天主教徒长大的。我们进入教堂时会用圣水祝福自己。洗礼和坚振圣事的圣礼涉及驱逐魔鬼。在欧洲和南美，天主教堂特别展示圣徒的遗物，实际上是人类的骨头。
And I'm sure we can name a lot of other practices that are similarly unorthodox. But where is the boundary between superstition and religious belief? What's the difference? How do we move from magical to something that's actually mystical and part of a dogma? Good question. You know, there are different ways to approach this. idea, but the way I would think about it, there are a couple of things I can say. First is, if the religious person is making a claim about the natural world, right? For example, that prayer can
我相信我们可以列举许多其他类似的非正统实践。但迷信与宗教信仰之间的界限在哪里？有什么区别？我们如何从魔法转向实际上是神秘的并属于教条的东西？好问题。你知道，有不同的方法来处理这个想法，但我会这样想，有几件事我可以说明。首先是，如果宗教人士正在对自然世界做出主张，对吧？例如，祈祷可以
heal people or that, or that the laying on of hands can heal people, right? Well, then I'm the kind of person who would say, I would like to see the evidence to support that. That's a natural world claim, it's testable, and I would place evidence above belief in that circumstance. However, there are many things, even some of the things you mention, where the people may engage in those practices, and they're not doing so while having any supernatural beliefs. I know that, I know, for example, that Holy Water is used in a number of ways in the church, and it does have a relationship to exorcism, to driving out the devil and so forth. But on the other hand, there is growing evidence.
治愈人，或者按手礼可以治愈人，对吧？嗯，那么我就是那种会说，我想看到支持这一点的证据的人。这是一个自然世界的主张，它是可测试的，在这种情况下，我会把证据置于信仰之上。然而，有很多事情，即使是你提到的一些事情，人们可能会参与这些实践，而他们在这样做时并没有任何超自然信仰。我知道，我知道，例如，圣水在教堂里以多种方式使用，它确实与驱魔、驱逐魔鬼等有关。但另一方面，有越来越多的证据。
There's some relatively interesting new line of research that suggests that rituals when practiced are beneficial, that both in the moment, that they lower anxiety if you're practicing doing a ritual and that they can, in some cases, enhance performance. But here's the thing. It doesn't matter whether the ritual is a religious or a superstitious ritual. It can be just a secular straight ritual. Someone tells you do these things. And so it's the ritual, not the belief.
有一些相对有趣的新研究方向表明，仪式在实践时是有益的，即在当下，如果你正在练习做仪式，它们会降低焦虑，并且在某些情况下，它们可以提高表现。但关键是。仪式是宗教仪式还是迷信仪式并不重要。它可以只是一个世俗的直接仪式。有人告诉你做这些事情。所以是仪式，而不是信仰。
And so I guess what I would say is that if you are believing, as you're performing these acts in a church or in a religious community, if you're believing in things that are not consistent with science as you do them, then you're possibly in the realm of superstition, because I think sciences ultimately are judge on those things, if they're testable. On the other hand, if you're doing them simply as part of a community, as a ritual that we do that shows that we are part of this community and for its immediate psychological benefits,
所以我猜我会说，如果你在教堂或宗教社区中执行这些行为时，如果你在做这些事情时相信与科学不一致的事情，那么你可能处于迷信的领域，因为我认为科学最终是我们对这些事情的判断者，如果它们是可测试的话。另一方面，如果你仅仅把它们作为社区的一部分来做，作为我们展示我们是这个社区一部分的仪式，并为了其直接的心理益处，
then without necessarily going over into the supernatural, then I wouldn't call it a superstition. I would call it a ritual that's part of a community and so on. So I think it's really all about how you are thinking about it as you do it. It's meaning for you and also the claims that you're making about it if you're thinking that it's going to have some benefit in the real world. So you've written that you are not superstitious yourself, but how did you become interested in study?
而不必进入超自然领域，那么我就不会称之为迷信。我会称之为社区仪式的一部分，等等。所以我认为这完全取决于你在做它时是如何思考它的。它对你意味着什么，以及如果你认为它会在现实世界中产生某种好处，你对它所做的主张。所以你写过你自己并不迷信，但你是如何对研究产生兴趣的？
the psychology of superstition. I mean, this is not, you know, a huge field of study within the discipline. True. Yeah. So that's a good question and one that I love to go back and think about. So I've discovered, for whatever reason, early on in my career, that I was interested in things that people do that don't quite make sense. Irrational things. That not things that are psychopathological, you know, not things that are psychological problems, but things that normal people do that are either against their own interests or just not quite rational. And I discovered long ago, I read an article that was actually by Barry Schwartz back when I was in graduate school. and it was an article about students doing a computer game where they were not told how it worked.
迷信的心理学。我的意思是，这不是学科内的一个巨大研究领域。真的。是的。所以这是一个好问题，也是我喜欢回过头来思考的问题。所以我发现，无论出于什么原因，在我职业生涯的早期，我就对人们所做的那些不太合理的事情感兴趣。非理性的事情。不是那些病理性的事情，你知道，不是心理问题，而是正常人做的那些要么违背他们自身利益，要么不太理性的事情。很久以前我发现，我在研究生院时读过一篇实际上是巴里·施瓦茨写的文章。那是一篇关于学生玩电脑游戏的文章，他们不知道它是如何工作的。
It was very simple, rudimentary computer game where they were just pressing buttons. And they were not told how it works, worked. And at the end, they were asked to describe, how did you get the points to come, right? Well, when the points didn't, came sort of randomly, they made up all these crazy theories. You have to go two over here and then three down. And I just found this so fascinating. And I went to my graduate advisor at the time and said, look, we have to drop everything and study this. This is really cool.
那是一个非常简单、原始的电脑游戏，他们只是在按按钮。他们不知道它是如何工作的。最后，他们被要求描述，你是如何得到分数的，对吧？嗯，当分数随机出现时，他们编造了所有这些疯狂的理论。你必须在这里按两次，然后向下按三次。我发现这太迷人了。我当时去找我的研究生导师说，看，我们必须放下一切来研究这个。这真的很酷。
And he sort of patted me on the head and said, no, go back and do your work. And when I finally got my own lab and could do my own research, I started to do some research on it. And it has kept me busy in one form or another for a long time. But I find the kind of foibles of human behavior to be both interesting and sort of endearing in a way. And so that has been the sort of overriding interest and continues to be to this day. So it would seem that we're pretty much hardwired to, if not be superstitious, we're always trying to make order out of chaos. And some of that seems to manifest itself in what you just described, people thinking that if you play the game,
他拍了拍我的头说，不，回去做你的工作。当我最终有了自己的实验室并能进行自己的研究时，我开始对它进行一些研究。它以这样或那样的形式让我忙碌了很长时间。但我发现人类行为的那些怪癖既有趣又在某种程度上令人喜爱。所以这一直是一种压倒性的兴趣，直到今天仍然如此。所以看起来我们似乎天生就倾向于，如果不是迷信，我们总是试图从混乱中建立秩序。其中一些似乎体现在你刚才描述的事情中，人们认为如果你玩游戏，
this way it's going to work for you. Right. Exactly. And some of the, you know, so it is, I think, hardwired into us. And there's a sense in which we sort of overdetermine the cause and effect relationships. You know, we, that many of the superstitions that, that have made, are maintained by individuals or have been maintained over the years, are kind of low cost, right? Like you could, and certainly the personal superstitions, not only the low cost, but in many cases they're private. You don't run out and tell people that necessarily that you have this lucky coin in your pocket or whatever. Maybe you will, but the trusted person, but it's not the first thing you tell people about. And so it can be
这样它就会为你工作。对。完全正确。而且其中一些，你知道，所以它是，我认为，天生就存在于我们体内。在某种意义上，我们有点过度决定了因果关系。你知道，我们，许多由个人维持或多年来一直维持的迷信，都是低成本的，对吧？就像你可以，当然个人迷信，不仅成本低，而且在许多情况下它们是私人的。你不一定会跑出去告诉别人你的口袋里有这枚幸运硬币什么的。也许你会，但对信任的人，但这不是你告诉别人的第一件事。所以它可以
employed simply and without much cost, and it makes you feel better in the moment. And so many superstitions, I think, are aimed at some kind of grasping at control, an illusion of control, if you will, and they're low-cost. They don't do any harm. In most cases, there are some that I think that are dangerous, but the great majority of superstitions are ones that we can employ, and it may look a little odd, but they don't cause any harm. What are the dangerous superstitions? I mean, you're taking us back to the Salem witch trials and some of those kinds of activities? Well, yes.
简单地使用，没有太多成本，而且让你在当下感觉更好。所以我认为许多迷信旨在某种程度上抓住控制权，如果你愿意的话，是一种控制的错觉，而且它们成本很低。它们不会造成任何伤害。在大多数情况下，有一些我认为是危险的，但绝大多数迷信是我们能够使用的，它可能看起来有点奇怪，但它们不会造成任何伤害。什么是危险的迷信？我的意思是，你把我们带回了塞勒姆女巫审判和那些活动？嗯，是的。
I'm hopeful that post-enlightenment, those are not, we're not going to have any more witch trials. But those were definitely, those were definitely dangerous beliefs. But no, I'm thinking more in terms of things like superstitions about gambling, which may keep you at the table longer than you should be. And people should recognize, you know, that gambling is the odds are against you. and that there is no luck. You know, the concept, people believing in the concept of luck,
我希望后启蒙时代，那些不是，我们不会再有女巫审判了。但那些绝对是，那些绝对是危险的信仰。但不，我更多地是在考虑像赌博迷信这样的事情，这可能会让你在桌子旁停留的时间比你应该停留的时间更长。人们应该认识到，你知道，赌博的赔率对你不利。而且没有运气。你知道，运气这个概念，人们相信运气这个概念，
that I can get lucky, can be dangerous in that situation. And, you know, it's all math. It's all very straightforward. There are some games that involve strategy. My understanding is that poker is a game that because there's a human factor, it's possible to win. But my understanding is that most professional poker players, if you work it out on an hourly basis,
我能走运，在这种情况下可能是危险的。而且，你知道，这全是数学。这非常直截了当。有些游戏涉及策略。据我了解，扑克是一种因为有人为因素而可能获胜的游戏。但据我了解，大多数职业扑克玩家，如果你按小时计算，
are not making much money, even if they are making money. The other thing is that I would put alternative medicines into the category of superstition. We don't think of it that way often, but many alternative medicines are inconsistent with science, and they are, you know, you're attempting to do something healthy with them, but they can be dangerous. You know, there have been cases of people who use homeopathic medicines or naturopathic medicines instead of going to a doctor with very dire results. And so that's an example where I think we should go with science and not adopt those alternative medicines. Are there any character traits that are consistent with people who are more likely?
并没有赚多少钱，即使他们确实赚了钱。另一件事是，我会把替代医学归入迷信的范畴。我们通常不这样想，但许多替代医学与科学不一致，而且它们是，你知道，你试图用它们做一些健康的事情，但它们可能是危险的。你知道，有案例表明人们使用顺势疗法或自然疗法而不是去看医生，结果非常可怕。所以这是一个我认为我们应该遵循科学而不是采用那些替代医学的例子。有没有什么性格特征与那些更有可能迷信的人一致？
to be superstitious or demographic groups or is it about age or sex or anything like that? Well, I think that I think the most important demographic is having grown up in a family where superstition is a real thing. You know, in other words, that we acquire so much from our families. We require our religions in most cases from our families. So it's just one of those things where you, if you don't grow up in a family where this is even thought, talked about or is in any way given credence, then you're not going to be superstitious. So that's a big thing. But once you are, once you are, it's a possibility with you that you might be superstitious. There are some personality traits that are, that are
是迷信还是人口统计学群体，又或者是年龄、性别之类的因素？嗯，我认为最重要的人口统计学因素是在一个将迷信视为真实存在的家庭中长大。换句话说，我们从家庭中习得了太多东西。在大多数情况下，我们从家庭中习得了宗教信仰。所以，如果你成长的家庭中从未提及、讨论过这些，或者根本不相信这些，那么你也就不会迷信。这是一个很大的因素。但一旦你处于那种环境，你就有可能变得迷信。有一些人格特质是与此相关的。
associated with it. Most of them not very pleasant. They're like trade anxiety. If you're an anxious person, you can imagine that would be the case. People who are high, and fear of death are slightly more likely to be superstitious. People who have this concept in psychology we talk about as being locus of control, meaning that you either have control inside yourself. I have control and I'm the master of my fate or the control is outside and I'm sort of buffeted by life. The people with external locus of control who feel as though they're low on their ability to control events are more likely to be superstitious in an effort to gain more control.
大多数特质并不怎么令人愉快。比如特质焦虑。如果你是一个焦虑的人，你可以想象这会是怎样的情况。对死亡有高度恐惧的人更有可能迷信。心理学中有一个概念叫“控制点”，意思是说，要么控制权在你内心，即“我掌控一切，我是自己命运的主宰”；要么控制权在外部，即“我被生活所左右”。那些具有外部控制点、感觉自己控制事件能力较弱的人，为了获得更多的控制感，更有可能变得迷信。
So there are some personality traits that have shown to be associated with it. But the good news on that front is that the relationships are all fairly weak. You know, if you're, for example, knowing that you have high anxiety is not going to give us a whole lot of information about whether you're superstitious or not, and vice versa. And so there are some relationships there that are sort of expected as you might. They go in the direction you might think they would, but they're not powerful. I think it's much more a case of your culture, your upbringing, and your personal experiences that are likely to make it happen.
所以，确实有一些人格特质被证明与迷信有关。但好消息是，这些相关性都相当微弱。例如，仅仅知道你是否有高度焦虑，并不能为我们提供太多关于你是否迷信的信息，反之亦然。因此，虽然存在一些符合预期的相关性，且方向也如你所想，但它们并不显著。我认为这更多地取决于你的文化、成长环境和个人经历，这些因素更有可能导致迷信的产生。
Is there a relationship between superstition and obsessive-compulsive disorder, which can look almost superstitious. if I have OCD and I need to count everything or go through rituals in order to leave the house. Yeah. I mean, this is the psychological disorder that looks the most like superstition. It is, you know, the compulsive rituals and so on that people must do or else something bad will happen. My understanding of this is that there isn't a whole lot of a relationship between the two. they look the same, but it's far more severe in the other case, in the OCD case. And there isn't any, you know, they've done studies where kids who are sort of anxious and ritualistic, young, whether they turn into people with OCD as they age.
迷信与强迫症之间是否存在某种联系？强迫症有时看起来几乎就像迷信。如果我有强迫症，我需要数清所有东西，或者在出门前必须完成某些仪式。是的，这是看起来最像迷信的心理障碍。那些人们必须执行的强迫性仪式，否则就会发生坏事，确实很像。据我了解，两者之间并没有太大的联系。它们看起来很像，但在强迫症的情况下，情况要严重得多。而且，据我所知，研究人员曾对那些年幼时焦虑且有仪式行为的孩子进行过研究，看他们长大后是否会患上强迫症。
And I don't think they've found anything that is a relationship there. The other thing to keep in mind is that, you know, according to surveys, 50% of people or more, I mean, say that there's at least a little superstitious. So it's pretty widespread. It's not something that we have to worry about it being a psychological problem unless it does get excessive, or if you choose these what I will call dangerous superstitions. Well, thank you for joining me today, Dr. Weiss. It's been really interesting talking to you.
我不认为他们发现了两者之间存在任何联系。另一件需要记住的事情是，根据调查，50%或更多的人表示他们至少有一点迷信。所以这非常普遍。除非它变得过度，或者你选择了所谓的“危险迷信”，否则我们不必担心它是一个心理问题。好的，感谢您今天加入我们，韦斯博士。与您交谈非常有趣。
and of course I wish you the best of luck in all your future endeavors. Thank you. You too. It was a pleasure to be here. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology at www.org or on Apple, Stitcher, or wherever you get your podcasts. And if you're inclined to, please leave us a review. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speakingof psychology at APA.org. That's Speaking of Psychology, all one word, at APA.org. Speaking of Psychology is produced by Lee Wynerman. Our sound editor is Chris Kondyin.
当然，我也祝愿您在未来的所有事业中一切顺利。谢谢。也祝您顺利。很高兴能来到这里。您可以在 www.org 或 Apple、Stitcher 以及任何您获取播客的地方找到《心理学谈话》往期节目。如果您愿意，请给我们留下评论。如果您对未来的播客有任何意见或想法，可以发送电子邮件至 speakingofpsychology@apa.org。那是 Speaking of Psychology，连在一起，后面接 @apa.org。《心理学谈话》由 Lee Wynerman 制作。我们的声音编辑是 Chris Kondyin。
Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
感谢您的收听。我是美国心理学会的 Kim Mills。本期节目目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。